if you're one of the millions of people
every year
entering EU borders from a third country
you need to be aware of an important new
rule under the EU Plant Health law you
cannot introduce any plant or plant
material into the EU unless it is
accompanied by an official certificate
from the Plant Health Authority in its
country of origin this simple rule will
be mandatory from December 2019 it's
been put in place to protect European
agriculture and forestry from the entry
and spread of new dangerous plant pests
and diseases which could be present on
imported plant fruit vegetable seed or
other living plant material the only
exceptions to it are bananas coconuts
dates pineapples and durians they do not
need a special certificate because they
do not pose such a risk plant pests that
do pose a risk can be very destructive
if they're not stopped at customs they
can rapidly spread damaging our green
spaces devastating crops and harming
Europe's beautiful landscapes its
agriculture and the health of our
environment with the new plant health
rule you can play a small but powerful
role in helping keep European territory
safe so please remember if you do not
have an official certificate for your
plant or plant material don't bring it
into the EU with you